se renueva El poder legislativo en
Italia este jueves se ha dado inicio a
la legislatura número 19 de la historia
republicana del país con la primera
sesión parlamentaria el orden del día
son las elecciones de los presidentes de
la cámara de diputados y del senado por
primera vez Estas dos cámaras del
parlamento se presentan en un nuevo
formato fruto de una reforma
constitucional que redujo el número de
parlamentarios Ahora son 400 diputados y
200 senadores un total de 600
parlamentarios que darán vida A partir
de hoy a un parlamento con equilibrios
inéditos por primera vez desde el
semifinal de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
el principal partido representado es una
formación postfasista que nació de las
cenizas de movimientos fundados por
antiguos fieles de Benito Mussolini se
trata del partido hermanos de Italia
liderado por Georgia melón y quien se
hipotisa podría recibir el encargo por
parte del presidente italiano Sergio
matarella de formar un nuevo gobierno
a partir de la próxima semana